STEPHANIE: There is both
a talent and a skills
gap in the workforce.
This is driven by a
number of factors,
including demands for speed,
innovation and flexibility
in fast-paced environments,
combined with a growing deficit
in technical proficiency.
Recent events have only
fueled this fire further,
and organizations are
looking for strategies
to reduce their talent
gaps now more than ever.
So how do organizations
solve for this?
I'm Stephanie,
and in this video,
we'll discuss why digital
upskilling your workforce
with AppSheet is one of the
most impactful decisions you
can make to improve resiliency.
Let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
No matter the industry
or job to be done,
the demand for digital skills
has increased dramatically.
There is an expectation
to work with technology
in nearly every component
of work, in part
because it is no longer
siloed to a singular function.
Daily duties for
a variety of jobs
include data analysis, process
improvement and automation,
to name a few.
With digital upskilling, you
can empower your workforce
to problem solve in a new way.
Not every person
on your team needs
to be a data or
development expert,
but they can leverage
democratized technology
to address their fundamental
line of business needs.
So whether you're an operator, a
marketing professional, or even
an IT specialist,
you will find value
in developing custom
solutions that
make your work even easier.
You just need the
right platform.
That's why we built AppSheet, a
platform that empowers anyone,
regardless of your role
in the organization,
to build custom applications and
automations with IT governance
and security in mind.
And since no coding
is required to be
successful with
the platform, it's
the perfect jumping off
point for digital upskilling.
Few organizations have the time
for the traditional development
cycles.
What is needed is a
problem-solving mentality,
secure data, and speed.
With AppSheet, the
platform's intelligence
does the heavy lifting.
Built-in machine learning
ingests selected data
from the approved source.
The intention of that
data is then analyzed,
producing a suggested
application or automation
prototype in a
matter of moments.
For example, data with
dates may produce a calendar
in your application to help
manage a series of projects
your data contains.
Furthermore,
non-technical workers
can enhance the custom
applications or automations
they're building with the
platform's natural language
capabilities.
You don't need to learn
how to code or invest
in additional development
talent to do this.
You simply need to learn how to
articulate the problem you're
trying to solve for with the
applications and automations
you wish to build.
Time and talent are
critical to the success
of any organization,
and we've learned
that the traditional
siloed ways of working
aren't as effective
as they once were.
With an innovative no-code
platform like AppSheet,
organizations are able to not
only upskill their workforce
to address talent
and skill gaps,
but they have the
confidence that they're
investing in a more digitally
resilient and engaged
workforce.
Ready to start your
no-code journey?
Click the link below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]